Counter-Strike 2 is finally here and
hype is at an all-time high but its new
engine isn't actually all that new
source 2 has been out since 2015. but if
you're not plugged into the world of
gaming engines what are the differences
well the biggest upgrade goes to the
improved graphical capabilities that
allow for more realistic lighting and
Reflections
next up Source 2 replaced Havoc with our
own custom physics engine which can
achieve extremely realistic cloth
simulation and collision detection which
we have already seen in Half-Life Alex
and caught a glimpse of in CS2 oh yeah
you can see the liquid look at that
liquid in the bottle epic asides from
those massive updates source2 provides a
more Dynamic audio engine enhanced
Panorama GUI lower latency and a
revamped map editor Alex was already a
technical model so I can't wait to see
how far valve can push Source 2 now that
CS2 is announced fingers crossed for
Left 4 Dead 3.